قبول الحرب النوويه تدق مره اخرى هذا ما
حذر منه الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو بوتيريش في الذكرى الثامنه
والسبعين للقصف الامريكي لمدينه هيروشيما
اليابانيه بالقنبله الذريه فما الذي حدث
ولماذا حين اندلعت الحرب العالميه الثانيه
كان عدد سكان هيروشيما يقدر باكثر من 340
الف نسمه وكانت المدينه تعتبر اهم المراكز
الصناعيه والعسكريه وثانيه الحواضر
اليابانيه الكبرى وتوجد فيها اهم القواعد
العسكريه والجزء الاهم من القاعده
الصناعيه العسكريه في البلاد مع تقهقر
اليابان امام قوات الحلفاء اصبحت هيروشيما
قاعده
ارتكاذها الاهم في دفاعها عن سيادتها وعن
حوزتها الترابيه امام تقدم الحلفاء فنقلت
اليها قياده الجيش وتم تركيز القوات
الجويه وانظمه الدفاع الصاروخي حولها
وفي ضوء هذه المعطيات وقع اختيار القاده
العسكريه الخادم العسكريه الامريكيه وقع
اختيارهم على هيروشيما لتكون هدف اول
قنبله ذريه
تستخدمها لحسم الحرب في السادس من اغسطس
عام
القت القاذفه الامريكيه
القنبله الذريه الطفل البديل القتها على
هيروشيما تسبب ذلك في دمار كلي في دائره
النصف قطرها قطرها كيلومتر
و600 متر كما دمر اكثر من 70% من مباني
المدينه جراء الانفجار النووي
قتل الالاف في الحال ونحو مئه واربعين
الفا اخرين بحلول نهايه العام واستسلمت
اليابان في الخامس عشر من اغسطس بطبيعه
الحال خضعت المدينه لبرنامج شامل لاعاده
الاعمار مكنها من استعاده مكانتها لكنه لم
ينجح في ازاله اثار التلوث النووي الذي لا
تزال اثاره باثره في شكل تشوهات خلقيه
للمواليد وتسمم الاشعاعي للغطاء النباتي
والمياه الجوفيه لكن ما خصوصيه ذكرى
هيروشيما هذه المره قبل ساعات
الامير العام للامم المتحده بتلويح بعض
الدول بالتهديد النووي مهدده باستخدام
اداه الاباده هذه وقال ان طبول الحرب
النوويه تقرع تقرع من جديد رئيس الوزراء
الياباني
في الشتاء اشاره صراحه اذا ما سماها
تهديدات روسيا النوويه غير المقبوله وقال
ان الدمار الذي احدثته الاسلحه النوويه في
هيروشي لا يمكن ان يتكرر ابدا وفي دعوه
مشتركه نادره من نوعها طالبت اكثر من 100
مجله طبيه عالميه بارزه بتحرك عاجل للتخلص
من الاسلحه النوويه محضره من ان خطر وقوع
كانت النوويه كبير ويتفاقم عن الاثار
المحتمله يقول
من الجمعيه العالميه للمحررين للمتخصصين
في المجال الطبيعي انه حتى اذا اندلعت حرب
نوويه محدوده تستخدم فيها 250 فقط الى
الاسلحه النوويه في العالم البارح عددها
13 الفا فيمكن ان يتسبب الامر في مقتل 120
مليون شخص فورا هذا الاحتمال المخيف
يمكن ان يتسبب ايضا في اضطراب المناخ في
العالم ما يؤدي الى مجاعه ناجمه عن
استخدام السلاح النووي ويشكل خطرا على
مليوني شخص وذلك بناء على ابحاث سابقه
ينضم الينا من مدينه ارسالا مدينه في
السويد الدكتور جرجري وهو باحث المتخصص في
دراسات السلامه والنزاع الدكتور جرجري بعد
نحو 80 عاما من القاء القنبله الذريه
الامريكيه على نجازاكي وهيروشيما يتحدث
الامين العام للامم المتحده على ان طبول
الحرب النوويه تقرع هل بالفعل توجد شواهد
على ان هذا احتمال حقيقي قائم في هذا
الوقت
هنالك احتماليه ربما احتماليه بعيده لكنها
لا يجب استبعادها لان لدينا تصعيد ومواجهه
في الصراعات بين
القوه الغربيه الكبرى وهي الولايات
المتحده والقوات غير الغربيه مثل روسيا
والصين وهي في صعود الان بالتالي لا يجب
ان نغض النظر بشكل تماما حتى ولو كان هذا
الاحتمال بعيدا الى اي مدى هو بعيد يعني
عندما نتحدث عن هيروشيما كانت هناك حرب
عالميه في ذلك الوقت هل الاجواء التي
نعيشها الان قريبه باي حال من الاحوال من
تلك الاجواء في عام 1945
هذه هي المرحله كلا
كان هنالك
في الحرب الحرب كان هنالك في حسابات
الولايات المتحده ان تلقي القنبله على
هيروشيما من اجل
ان
توقف
توقف خساره الارواح في بين القوات
الامريكيه القوه القنبله الثانيه كانت لم
تكن ضد اليابان اذا كانت لتحذير الاتحاد
السوفيتي وتم تقرير اتخاذ هذا القرار بعد
استسلام اليابان وكان هذا الامر في نهايه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه اذا مانع ننظر الى
الوضع الان لدينا مقاربتان مختلفتان لهذه
العقيده النوويه لدينا روسيا والتي
تقوم باتخاذ اجراءات انتقاميه او تهدد
باتخاذ اجراءات الانتقاليه الولايات
المتحده ما لديه تحتفظ بامكانيه
ضربه الاولى
ولكنها هي ربما قد يكون هذا كل هذه الامور
قد تكون تصريحات غبيه وقصيره النظر اذا
نظرنا الى التاريخ ونظرنا الى حجم الدمار
المتخصصون يقولون ان حتى حرب نوويه محدوده
يمكن ان تقضي على 120 مليون شخص فورا
ورئيس الوزراء الياباني يقول انما حدث في
هيروشيما كان مرعبا للغايه بحيث لا يجب ان
يلوح احد بحرب نوويه هل يمكن ان يقع
العالم في هذا الفخ مره اخرى رغم كل
الاثار الكارثيه
انا اوافق مع هذه المقوله من الغباء
التحدث عن حرب نوويه محدوده من هو ما هو
المحدد اذا ما بدانا بشيء هل هنالك اي
ضماد انها سيتوقف عند مرحله معينه كلا لن
يحصل ذلك
كانهم نفتح بؤره للمشاكل ومن الصعب تحديد
والسيطره على نتائجها بالتالي لا يجب
علينا ان نتحاشى ان ناخذ في هذا الامر منذ
بدايته شكرا جزيلا لك من مدينه اوصله في
السويد الدكتور جريجري سايمنز
بلنس الباحث المختص في دراسات السلام
والنزاعات شكرا جزيلا